[Musik]
phoenix persönlich er will cdu-chef
werden und vermutlich auch
kanzlerkandidat friedrich merz herzlich
willkommen bei phoenix persönlich herr
merz sei trotzdem liegt jetzt an der
korona winterfahrplan für deutschland
auf dem tisch hat der hand und fuß
gesehen
ich versuche mich immer in die position
der bundeskanzlerin der
ministerpräsidenten zu versetzen und die
haben sie im augenblick nun wirklich
nicht leicht die erwartungen der
bevölkerung sind groß die gefahr über
die pandemie ist immer noch sehr groß
und insofern finde ich haben sie einen
guten weg gefunden vor allen dingen
jetzt bis zum jahresende oder bis zum
beginn des nächsten jahres auch einmal
eine perspektive zu geben wie es
weitergeht
ich habe immer gesagt man braucht ein
bisschen mehr zeithorizont einfach auch
um die bevölkerung ein bisschen auch zu
versichern wie es weiter
das haben sie gut gemacht nun blicken
nach den november helfen inzwischen auch
die dezember hilfen auf dem tisch
weitere 17 milliarden für das nächste
jahr 160 milliarden unterstützung durch
den bund wo soll denn das ganze geld
noch herkommen
naja der finanzminister hat ja nun das
portemonnaie ist ja weit aufgemacht wir
machen in diesem jahr schulden im
nächsten jahr nochmal wir nehmen die
schuldenbremse aus dem grundgesetz
praktisch heraus und geben so viel geld
aus wie wir für eine ganze generation
eigentlich nur schulden machen dürfen
das muss die junge generation irgendwann
bezahlen und deswegen sage ich auch es
hat alles seine grenzen es geht nicht
alles man kann nicht jeden umsatz aus
dem steuer haushalt ersetzen
und insofern ist da auch ein bisschen
maßhalten geboten
die koalition sagt in diesen stunden und
ringt um den abschluss des
bundeshaushaltes für 20 21 das wird eine
schwierige operation
wenn sie nun sagen sie wollen die
schulden bringen sie dann doch in
irgendeiner form irgendwann wieder
anziehen das würde eventuell bedeuten
dass es doch eine platte welle gibt weil
die unterstützung nicht mehr so lange
gegeben wird wenn sie mit der jungen
generation argumentieren haben die nicht
auch probleme wenn wir jetzt relativ
zügig in eine form von pleitewelle gehen
also ich sehe die platte werde nicht ich
sehe sie weder für dieses jahr noch für
das nächste jahr wir werden unternehmen
in der insolvenz ihn keine frage wir
hatten auch eine ganze reihe von
unternehmen die schon vor corona in
einer sehr schwierigen lage waren
da hilft keine im augenblick ein
bisschen über die zeit aber das wird
nach corona nicht besser bei vielen
unternehmen
andere werden durch die korona hilfen
gerettet und das ist ja nun gerade der
sinn der übung für das jahr 2020 und für
das jahr 2021 in beiden jahren stehen
umfangreiche hilfen des bundes zur
verfügung
es ist in diesen tagen darauf
hingewiesen worden ich habe mir die
zahlen auch noch mal angeschaut wir
machen mehr als die hälfte aller hilfen
die in der gesamten europäischen union
für die unternehmen und für die
arbeitsplätze gegeben werden in
deutschland mehr als die hälfte wie in
ganz europa also ich glaube wir brauchen
uns nicht zu verstecken
man wird seit gestern ja auch der
vorschlag auf dem tisch der vorschlag
des bundes dass die länder sich
beteiligen müssen an den kosten wäre das
ein gangbarer weg
ich halte die beteiligung der länder für
unverzichtbar im jahr 2021 werden die
länder das erste mal aus den großen
steuerarten die wir haben mehr einnahmen
haben als der bund das hat eine
verschiebung auch durch die verschiebung
der anteile zum beispiel an der
umsatzsteuer in den letzten jahren immer
zugunsten der länder gegeben
der bund verhandelt ja auch immer aus
einer position 16 gegen einen und
insofern sind die länder jetzt natürlich
alle haushalte sind angespannt aber dass
die länder dazu beitragen dieses problem
zu lösen halte ich für
selbstverständlich
die spd-ministerpräsidenten wiederum
haben den vorschlag corona soli
eingebracht was halten sie davon
also wenn der bundesfinanzminister sagt
spitzenkandidat der spd für die
bundestagswahl wir können uns alles
leisten dann verstehe ich nicht warum
die spd ministerpräsidenten einen
solidaritätszuschlag vorschlagen noch
bevor der alte soli ganz abgeschafft ist
also darüber hat es glaube ich in der
öffentlichkeit in der wissenschaft in
der wirtschaft ohnehin und auch in der
bevölkerung zu recht erhebliche
vorbehalte gegeben
kernpunkt dieses winterfahrplan es war
ja auch die frage wie gehen wir mit
weihnachten um kontakt beschränkungen ja
oder nein nun sieht es so aus dass wir
bis kurz vor weihnachten nur noch mit
fünf leuten aus zwei haushalten uns
treffen sollen
und dann wird es gelockert von
weihnachten bis neujahr halten sie das
für den richtigen weg wählt
ärztepräsident montgomery befürchtet
dass dadurch ein fest mit todesrisiko
wie er sagt wird das ist eine abwägung
die die politik machen muss im hinblick
auf das infektionsrisiko gegen das recht
der familien weihnachten zu feiern
und ich finde dass diese abwägung gut
gelungen ist
auf der einen seite zu sagen bitte jetzt
keine großen begegnungen mehr keine
großen kontakte mehr dann aber über
weihnachten den familien freizustellen
auch mit den kindern weihnachten zu
feiern
wir leben hier nicht in einer diktatur
sondern wir leben in einer demokratie
und demokratie setzt voraus dass
menschen sich verantwortungsvoll auch
gegenüber dem land auch gegenüber ihren
familien auch gegenüber sich selbst
verhalten und dieser appell den die
politik gegeben hat dem schließe ich
mich ausdrücklich an
wenn der staat nicht kontrollieren soll
und ich finde er darf auch nicht
kontrollieren
dann müssen sich die menschen
verantwortungsvoll verhalten und das
gilt gerade in diesem jahr zu
weihnachten für viele menschen in
deutschland ist weihnachten in der tat
ja auch das wichtigste fest auch ihnen
scheint es sehr wichtig zu sein sie
haben mit einem tweet aufsehen erregt
vor allen dingen garzeit in dem sie
geschrieben haben es geht den staat
nichts an wie ich mit meiner familie
weihnachten feiere
sagen sie das auch heute ich lese dass
in einigen zeitungen wortgleich wieder
in einer großen tageszeitung im
kommentar genau diese formulierung
ich reklamiere da gar nicht die
urheberschaft für mich sondern ich finde
es ist so es gibt einen geschlossenen
raum der privatsphäre nicht ohne grund
steht dass auch in unserer verfassung so
und wenn ich dann sage das den status
nichts angeht wenn sich die menschen an
die regeln halten und vernünftig sind im
umgang miteinander
dann gibt es einen geschlossenen
geschützten raum und das ist mein
privates haus meine private wohnung
meine private umgebung und gerade zu
weihnachten aber die kehrseite ist
vernunft augenmaß und bitte auch ein
stück verantwortungsbewusstsein bei
allen betroffenen
was sagen sie denn denen die ihm
vorwerfen sie polarisieren damit in
einer ohnehin schwierigen zeit in der er
die mehrheit der deutschen auch die
beschlüsse der bundesregierung beträgt
sehen sie und wenn ich sie jetzt auch so
verteidige und soundso unterstreiche wo
ist da die polarisierung ich sehe die
dinge kritisch ich versuche sie auch zu
hinterfragen wenn sie hinterfragt werden
müssen immer wieder zu dem ergebnis und
ich habe das ganze jahr 2020 immer
wieder gesagt ich gehöre zu den
vorsichtigen und deswegen habe ich auch
immer die entscheidungen der
bundesregierung im großen und ganzen für
richtig gehalten auch das was die
ministerpräsidenten gemacht habe ich
habe sogar meinen eigenen
ministerpräsidenten armin laschet vor
ungerechtfertigter kritik in schutz
genommen also persönlichkeit festaktes
gar nicht mehr kommen wir mal zu den
wettbewerb um den parteivorsitz auch da
gab es empfiehlt der für irritationen
gesorgt hat ihrerseits und zwar haben
sie hinter der verschiebung des
parteitages zunächst taktische manöver
vermutet ich lese in denen mal vor damit
ich auch bloß keine keine fehler mache
sie haben geschrieben ich habe klare
hinweise darauf dass armin laschet die
devise ausgegeben hat er brauche mehr
zeit um seine performance zu verbessern
ist der ihr temperament mit ihnen
durchgegangen
was ist daran so temperamentvoll wenn
ich einfach diese hinweise mal auf nehme
die ich nun in der tat auch harte und
zwar nicht nur einen sondern mehrere
wir haben uns jetzt verständigt so was
hat man einmal gekracht wir haben uns
jetzt darauf verständigt dass wir mitte
januar den parteitag abhalten details
werden im augenblick intensiv diskutiert
es gibt einen gemeinsamen vorschlag
aller drei kandidat
indem wir der partei unterbreitet haben
dass wir nämlich mitte januar den
parteitag abhalten den wir eigentlich
schon im april machen wollten
im oktober erweckt haben im dezember
festgelegt hatten und nun alles wegen
corona schwierig geworden ist aber das
enthebt uns nicht der verpflichtung ein
parteitag zu machen und auch einen neuen
vorstand für die cdu deutschlands zu
wählen ich kann ihnen einen weiteren
verfahren ist alles es läuft seit
sonntag der letzte teil der aktion märz
verhindern in der cdu und das mit der
vollen breitseite des establishments
hier in berlin haben sie geschrieben
frau kühlt das thema ist durch und
erledigt noch mal wir haben einmal einen
streit gehabt der iss erledigt wir uns
geeinigt und jetzt gucken wir nach vorne
ok lassen wir also stehen jetzt kommt
aber armin laschet endspiel der wiederum
nun auch konzert übrigens ein verhalten
was wir aus der cdu ja normalerweise
nicht so kennen
normalerweise sind sie zumindest
öffentlich immer sehr einer meinung
armin laschet hat gesagt er hätte sie
für professioneller gehalten
früher gegen merkel jetzt gegen
irgendwelches establishment immer eine
verschwörungstheorie vermuten wir mal
eine sache entscheidung fällt das passe
einfach nicht
sind sie auch damit sind miteinander
jetzt wieder im reinen nein also ich
nehme mir das so hin was er sagt ich bin
niemand der verschwörungstheorien
anhängt und das ist jetzt eine
geschichte gewesen die hat stattgefunden
und damit es gut
kommen wir zu einer frau die noch
amtierende cdu chefin annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat in der öffentlichkeit
beklagt dass sie sich da gegenseitig
einen ruinösen wettbewerb liefern was
entgegnen sie ihr das ist eine
einschätzung die wir alle drei wenn ich
es richtig sehe nicht teilen
armin laschet nicht der norbert röttgen
nicht und die ich auch nicht wir haben
einen wettbewerb der dauert nun
allerdings auch schon ziemlich lange wir
haben es schon aufgrund der entscheidung
von annegret kramp karrenbauer die von
mitte februar datiert nicht wieder für
den parteivorsitz zu kandidieren jetzt
fast zehn monate diese diskussion und
das macht natürlich in der partei schon
eine gewisse unruhe
und deswegen drängen wir gemeinsam
darauf dass dieser termin und auch
stattfindet und dass wir wählen
ja es ist eine anstrengende zeit
es ist eine belastete zeit für alle aber
gerade deshalb wollen wir sie auch so
schnell wie möglich abschließen
wie groß ist denn die spaltung im moment
in der cdu jeder sammelt seine
gewährsleute hinter sich kasan am anfang
keine spaltung in der cdu es gab sie
auch 2018 nicht
es hat 2018 auch gerade von mir
persönlich aber auch von denen die mich
unterstützt haben
für annegret kramp karrenbauer jede
hilfe und unterstützung gegeben sie
werden nicht ein einziges kritisches
wort von mir ihr gegenüber finden weder
öffentlich noch nicht öffentlich ich
habe immer versucht ihr zu helfen und
sie zu unterstützen
und genau so erwarte ich dass im falle
meiner wahl auch die unterstützung der
gesamten partei mir zugute kommt und
umgekehrt gebe ich sie wenn ich nicht
gewinnen sollte jedem der dann die wahl
gewinnt das ist eine phase mit der die
cdu jetzt umgehen muss wir haben das
nicht sehr häufig die letzte
parteivorsitzende vor annegret kramp
karrenbauer war 18 jahre im amt und
insofern ist es für die cdu nichts was
wir nun ganz regelmäßig machen und wo
wir sozusagen routine entwickeln unsere
parteivorsitzenden auszutauschen das
überlassen der anderen werden wir noch
mal kurz vor 20 87 mal abgelegt in der
partei weiter zu machen sie wollten
zunächst ein minister abend das ging
aber nicht
und dann haben sie sich zurückgezogen
sind sie kein mann für die zweite reihe
muss man auch nicht in der zweiten reihe
dabei auch das ist eine schöne
geschichte die aber durch wiederholung
nicht richtiger wird ich habe 2018 nicht
für den vorstand kandidieren ich habe
nicht für das präsidium kandidiert weil
ich dort zum beispiel armin laschet oder
die heutige kommissionspräsidentin
ursula von der leyen verdrängt hätte das
war nämlich immer die mit die
schlechtesten ergebnisse bekommen habe
und da hab ich gesagt das mache ich
nicht
wir hätten im übrigen auch bei frau von
der leyen noch mal wählen müssen weil
wir das damalige quorum nicht erfüllt
hätten also ich habe davon abgesehen
gerade um weiteren streit zu vermeiden
ich habe meine hilfe der partei
angeboten das ist auch angenommen worden
so und da hat sich nichts daran geändert
ich habe die letzten beiden jahre
intensiv an verschiedenen themen
gearbeitet habe jederzeit meine
bereitschaft gezeigt auch mitzuhelfen
und mitzuarbeiten
ich bin in wahlkämpfen unterwegs gewesen
wie kein zweiter also dieser vorwurf
ist wirklich völlig abhängig jetzt geht
es wieder los geht kommt die nächste
abstimmung welche rolle kommt denn
diesmal angela merkel zu man geht ja
schon davon aus dass 20 18 durchaus mit
ihrem wunsch zusammengehangen hat dass
sie natürlich an der gdc am cover
favorisierte welche rolle glauben sich
richtig diesmal wir sind in einer
anderen lage 2018 waren wir gerade ein
jahr in der laufenden wahlperiode
und da gab es im parlament bei vielen
die befürchtung wenn der märz gewählt
wird gibt es neuwahlen und dann sehen
wir nicht so gut aus jetzt gibt es eine
völlig andere stimmungslage die ich war
nämlich hier in berlin auch in der
bundestagsfraktion von vielen die sagen
wenn der märz gewählt wird wenn ich
meinen wahlkreis so und von daher ist
die ausgangslage eine andere
im übrigen ist es so diese wahlperiode
geht im nächsten jahr zu ende
wenn wir diesen bundesparteitag haben im
januar sind wir acht monate vor der
nächsten bundestagswahl
und das heißt wir konzentrieren uns dann
in der arbeit in der partei
weitestgehend darauf diese
bundestagswahl vorzubereiten
das heißt wir richten dann den blick
über die zeit 2021 hinaus und ich werde
die partei antreiben das auch zu tun
denn wir haben eine menge arbeit zu
leisten wir müssen viele inhaltliche
themen klären
wir müssen die ganzen zukunftsfragen
noch mal beantworten wie wir sie denn
sehen für die nächsten zehn jahre
und deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass es
ein völlig problemlos nebeneinander von
partei und regierung gibt im übrigen
frau merkel und ich wir haben einen
vernünftigen austausch miteinander
wir reden miteinander wir haben kein
problem wir hatten sie in der
vergangenheit das ist vergangenheit wir
blicken jetzt nach vorn
es gibt ja das heißt sie sagen es gibt
keine alten wunden immerhin hat sie im
jahr 2002 den fraktions frau kühn
sie hatte ihn mir nicht weggenommen
sondern ich habe damals aus guten
gründen nicht kandidiert weil ich gesagt
habe beides muss in eine hand in der
opposition wie in der regierung muss
parteivorsitz und fraktionsvorsitz
parteivorsitz und kanzler in einer hand
so und das war damals die ausgangslage
die umstände haben mir nicht gefallen
ich habe da zwischen wunderbare zehn
jahre gehabt ich bin viele jahre jetzt
nicht in der politik gewesen und das ist
überhaupt kein problem so ist das so und
das habe ich immer akzeptiert ist die
cdu überhaupt vorstellbar ohne
angela merkel sie ist die beliebteste
politikerin in deutschland viele
menschen vertrauen ihr was glauben sie
wie die sich jetzt auf umfragewerte und
ähnliches auswirken wird wenn sie nicht
mehr an der spitze steht das ist eine
frage mit der wir uns ausführlich
beschäftigen weil natürlich die
bevölkerung erst im laufe der nächsten
monate verstehen wird dass diese angela
merkel dann nach der nächsten
bundestagswahl egal wie sie ausgeht
nicht mehr dabei ist wir haben das erste
mal eine bundestagswahl seit 1949 das
erste mal bei der der amtierende
bundeskanzler die amtierende
bundeskanzlerin sich nicht um die
wiederwahl bewirbt das heißt wir werden
eine völlig andere konstellation
personelle konstellation in der nächsten
bundestagswahl haben und wir werden auch
nicht für aus dankbarkeit für die
vergangenheit gewählt sondern wir werden
mit erwartungen für die zukunft gewählt
da stehen wir auf einem festen fundament
aber welches gebäude wir in der zukunft
darauf aufbauen das muss dann die
nächste politische generation definieren
und das ist eine herkulesaufgabe
bleiben wir mal bei den wählern und
wählerinnen vor allen dingen das sind ja
immerhin die hälfte der bevölkerung
und genau und bei den frauen in der cdu
sie haben in einem interview gesagt
sobald der termin für den parteitag
stünde sechzehnter januar würden sie den
namen ihrer eventuellen generalsekretär
nennen wer wird es dann ja also ganz
präzise ich habe gesagt wenn die
einladung für diesen parteitag
verschickt wird gebe ich bekannt wer aus
meiner sicht den delegierten
vorgeschlagen wird für das amt des
generalsekretärs oder der
generalsekretär in so und genau daran
halte ich mich wie weit sind sie damit
sehr bald 30 prozent parteimitglieder in
der cdu sind frauen 20 prozent in der
fraktion das ist eher dürftig woran
liegt das
das ist sehr dürftig wir haben es auch
in den letzten jahren offensichtlich
nicht geschafft den anteil unserer
weiblichen mitglieder signifikant zu
erhöhen
ich bedauere das sehr ich sehe sogar die
gefahr dass die nächste bundestags
fraktion noch mal weniger frauen haben
wird als diese weil zurzeit wir haben
ein luxusproblem sozusagen
wir wählen fast keine abgeordneten über
die listen sondern wir gewinnen in
deutschland fast alle wahlkreise so und
dafür muss sich nun auch kein mann
entschuldigen
im gegenteil wir gewinnen halt die
wahlkreise gleichzeitig sind damit aber
die einwirkungsmöglichkeiten von oben
von der bundes partei und von den
landesparteien sehr begrenzt was die
zusammensetzung der nächsten bundestags
fraktion betrifft das kümmere mich im
augenblick intensiv um einzelfälle
ermutige frauen unterstütze frauen auch
die wieder kandidieren wollen
es ist ein schwieriges unterfangen und
das problem ist nicht oben sondern das
problem ist unten so wie sie es gerade
richtig beschrieben haben wir haben zu
wenig frauen insbesondere zu wenig junge
frauen in der cdu und daran müssen wir
ganz hart arbeiten und darüber
diskutieren wir auch sehr intensiv
sie haben in dem zusammenhang von
männerlastigen arbeitsabläufen in der
politik gesprochen was haben sie denn
damit gemeint ja genau so wie es gemeint
habe natürlich ich sag mal das muster
ist doch häufig genug noch so dass die
frauen zu hause bleiben sich um die
kinder kümmern und die männer in die
politik gehen in die in die
veranstaltungen abends und dann noch ein
bier an der theke trinken das ist
männerlastig so und deswegen müssen wir
andere formate entwickeln wir müssen
andere uhrzeiten haben wir müssen andere
veranstaltungsformen machen andere
beteiligungsformen das gibt es heute und
wir haben doch nur durch corona auch
gesehen welche möglichkeiten wir dazu
haben das muss auch in der parteiarbeit
bei uns noch viel deutlicher umgesetzt
werden und das werden wir auch tun
wissen sie denn da nicht den einen oder
anderen widerstand auch noch ein rennen
ich meine jetzt mal stichwort boys
network ist natürlich auch schön wenn
man gewöhnt des abends dann beim wirt zu
sein
erste frage und zweite frage warum gehen
in ihren augen die frauen nicht so gern
mit zum bier
häufig genug immer noch die
arbeitsteilung die ist dass die frauen
sich zu hause um die kinder kümmern und
er zu hause sind als die männer was
wiederum auch mit einem männern liegen
natürlich das liegt an den männern also
ich sehe ich bei meinen kindern heute
mit großer freude und das ist auch
zunehmend anders herum geht und das ist
gut funktioniert ich fördere das ich
will dass nach kräften unterstützen
ermöglichen und ich werde viel dafür tun
dass sich das ändert und
das ist nicht die frage ob ein mann oder
eine frau an der spitze der partei steht
das ist der gemeinsame gute wille den
wir aufbringen müssen
ich sage auch meinen eigenen partei von
wenn wir dieses problem nicht lösen dann
verlieren wir die strukturelle
mehrheitsfähigkeit in deutschland und
das problem müssen wir lösen und
arbeiten wir sehr hart dran wenn wir bei
diesem problem die quote als türöffner
sehen würden die sie ja in der
vergangenheit doch eher skeptisch
beurteilt haben machen sie da ihre
einstellung geändert
nein ich sehe dass immer noch kritisch
ich sag immer das ist die zweitbeste
lösung die bessere wäre gewiss von unten
besser hinbekommen
wahrscheinlich werden wir ohne eine
solche quoten regelung nicht auskommen
aber das alleine reicht nicht so wir
müssen besser werden in der rekrutierung
von unten
ich will noch einen schritt weiter gehen
wir müssen in der partei
personalrekrutierung mechanismen
etablieren
wir müssen schulungen machen wir müssen
junge leute heranführen heranbilden auch
für ämter vorbereiten das machen andere
besser als wir
und deswegen werde ich mich als
parteivorsitzender sehr intensiv um die
nachwuchsausbildung und um moderne
personalführung in der partei kümmern
da sind wir zurzeit in jeder hinsicht
nicht gut genug das ist nicht nur eine
frage mangelnder repräsentanz der frauen
da ist die partei insgesamt nicht gut
genug aufgestellt
sie haben in der letzten zeit gesagt
frauen in der politik als quote würden
sie eventuell mitgehen oder könnten sie
sich vorstellen für die wirtschaft haben
sie das eher ausgeschlossen warum
glauben sie frauen kann politik aber
wirtschaftlich schließt das gar nicht
aus für die wirtschaft ich hab nur auf
diesen konkreten vorschlag der jetzt
gerade gemacht worden ist ein paar
hinweise gegeben dass das praktikabel
sein muss auch da haben wir ein problem
und sie können das problem sogar sehr
präzise beschreiben wir haben in
deutschland anders als in anderen
ländern schauen sie zum beispiel mal
nach frankreich die sind da viel weiter
als wir
wir haben in deutschland zu wenig junge
frauen in den technischen berufen
ich habe nun vielfältige berufliche
erfahrung auch in der besetzung von
vorständen
es ist extrem schwierig zb für
technische berufe in technischen
unternehmen frauen für die vorstände zu
bekommen das ist extrem schwierig so und
das kann man nicht einfach per gesetz
anordnen dafür braucht man strukturen
und an diesen strukturen muss
gemeinsam arbeiten wo sie sich da was
abschauen könnten wären die grünen die
ja wieder was junge leute an geht noch
was die frauen angeht ein vergleichbares
problem haben wir die cdu das könnt ihr
denn von denen lernen
ich beobachte sehr genau was die machen
also mit allem selbstbewusstsein
wir liegen als cdu in der bevölkerung
trotz dieser defizite immer noch doppelt
so gut in den wahlen und in den umfragen
wie die grünen trotzdem schaue ich mir
das an was die machen die sind zurzeit
in ihrer führung gut koordiniert die
haben das auch geschafft in der struktur
ihrer mitgliedschaft mehr frauen zu
begeistern für die mitarbeit dass es
offensichtlich attraktiver dort zu sein
als bei uns und sie bereiten auch viele
mitglieder auf die übernahme von
politischen ämtern gut vor
also ich habe kein problem damit zu
sagen die sind da gut aufgestellt wir
müssen es auch sein und wir müssen den
ehrgeiz haben sogar besser zu sein
die grünen haben auf ihrem parteitag
unlängst ein eher pragmatisches
grundsatzprogramm verabschiedet viele
glauben dass es auch schon damit
zusammenhängt dass man doch liebäugelt
mit einer koalition im bund im nächsten
jahr
wie haben sie denn den parteitag
verfolgt also vorgehen wenn ich in einer
solchen wohnzimmeratmosphäre gesessen
hätte wie die grünen der wäre ein
shitstorm in dieser republik über mich
gekommen
mit retro und 80er jahre aber das können
sie offen sich die die grünen leisten
ich mache es nicht gut also das war aber
nur das äußerliche inhaltlich muss ich
sagen respekt einige positionen auch neu
definiert nehmen wir mal nur das ganze
thema biotechnologie und gentechnik
aller bonne heure
das bedeutet dann aber bitte auch dass
die vorfeldorganisationen der grünen die
grüne jugend und andere aufhören in
deutschland die versuchsanlagen zu
zerstören ich bin immer schon der
meinung gewesen dass wir diese
technologie hier brauchen gut dass die
gründen darauf einschwenken
ich bin auch
erstaunt darüber was sie zum thema
infrastruktur und andere themen
beschlossen haben
dann würde es aber auch bedeuten dass
dann die bitte die grüne jugend und die
vorfeldorganisationen der grünen
aufhören
in seiner fast gegen den ausbau der a 49
zu protestieren also dann machen was
bitte ganz konkret parteitagsbeschlüsse
sind das eine das praktische handeln in
der politik ist das andere
können sie sich denn die grünen als
koalitionspartner zunächst einmal hat
einer der beiden vorsitzenden der grünen
klar erklärt dass er mit uns nicht
zusammenarbeiten will das nehme ich zur
kenntnis
dann schauen wir mal wie die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind die grünen
sind nach wie vor eine partei die lieber
mit den sozialdemokraten und der
linkspartei zusammen arbeitet als mit
uns schauen wir wie die
mehrheitsverhältnisse im nächsten jahr
sind jeder kämpft für sich allein
zugleich haben sie aber auch angekündigt
sie wollen einen großteil der afg wähler
zurückholen wenn wir jetzt einfach mal
ein kleines gedankenspiel machen
gegebenenfalls eine anbahnung einer
schwarz grünen koalition und zugleich im
wahlprogramm dass jeder vertreten
müssten einen zurückholen der afg wähler
das scheint irgendwie schlecht
vorstellbar sein wenn sie ist richtig
beobachten dann sage ich das seit zwei
jahren nicht mehr ich habe das 2018
gesagt zu einer völlig anderen zeit die
afg hat sich mittlerweile selbst fast
halbiert sie liegt jetzt noch bei zehn
prozent steigt allerdings leicht auch
wieder das muss man schon zur kenntnis
nehmen aber diejenigen die heute noch
bei der afg sind sind ganz überwiegend
wählerinnen und wähler nicht
ausschließlich aber ganz überwiegend
wählerinnen und wähler die so weit
abgedriftet sind dass sie für die cdu
kein potenzial mehr darstellen da gibt
es jetzt wahl enthaltungen es gibt viele
die auch in die innere emigration
gegangen sind die auch ein bisschen
frustriert sind
ich glaube dass wir aus denen die heute
nicht wählen viele zurückgewinnen können
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass wir auch
die wahlbeteiligung in deutschland mit
einem spannenden interessanten an
themenorientierten wahlkampf nach oben
bringen können wir müssten eigentlich
das ziel haben deutlich über 75 prozent
wahlbeteiligung in deutschland zu liegen
und da liegt ein großes potential für
die union und wenn wir uns gut
aufstellen dann können wir 35 plus auch
bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
erreichen das ist eine schwierige
aufgabe aber das heißt auch wir müssen
breit genug und tief genug in dieser
gesellschaft verankert sein
kommen noch mal auf die nächsten wochen
die sie ja extrem spannend werden wir
waren jetzt gerade eben schon digitalen
parteitag der grünen sie sagen sie
setzten sich in kein wohnzimmer setzen
wissen sie denn schon wie es etwas was
wir hier haben das gefährt das ist ja
nicht meine idee gewesen aber es ist
trotzdem okay also das kann ich noch gar
nicht sagen wir planen ja einen
digitalen parteitag den werden wir
machen müssen wir können wahrscheinlich
keinen präsenz parteitag machen
da gibt es eine letzte kleine hoffnung
dass es vielleicht doch geht aber wenn
wir mitte januar schauen jetzt haben wir
ende november die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass wir innerhalb von sechs wochen eine
durchgreifende verbesserung der lage
haben dass wir ein präsent parteitag
machen können ist nicht sehr groß
also müssen wir uns auf den digitalen
parteitag vorbereiten digital wählen das
wird eine technisch und juristisch
anspruchsvolle aufgabe auch
datensicherheit zu haben
übertragungssicherheit von jedem platz
wo ein delegierter zu hause sitzt das
ist nicht trivial
trotzdem denke ich wird es gehen es gibt
möglichkeiten die jetzt auch noch einmal
abschließend geprüft werden ja und dann
verbinde ich damit den anspruch dass wir
eine der modernsten wenn ich die
modernste partei in deutschland sind die
solche technischen möglichkeiten nutzt
die solche partizipationsmöglichkeiten
nutzt die einfach auch den menschen ob
jung ob alt die möglichkeit gibt in ganz
deutschland an der arbeit der cdu dazu
nehmen und das wäre für uns ein großer
fortschritt wenn wir es hinkriegen
der generalsekretär plant das und macht
das mit viel fantasie viel engagement
ich unterstütze das nach kräften ich
hoffe das gemeinsam hinbekommen
digitaler parteitag ist ja schon eine
herausforderung um sag ich jetzt mal so
profan einfach rüber zu kommen
auch emotionen und ähnliches
transportieren sich da eher weniger nun
hat der ein oder andere das gefühl sie
sind ja ohnehin ein eher kühler mensch
oder cooler typ
wie wollen sie denn ihr feuer und ihr
temperament die gitarre war auch das
sagen wir aber viele sagen mir viele
andere ich wäre ganz anders und ich
müsste doch an die auf eine präsenz
parteitag warten weil ich dann da besser
reden könnte weiß ja 20 18 mich weg
warst wir haben es also 20 18 liegt
jetzt lange zurück
ich fühle mich natürlich in
präsenzveranstaltungen auch wohler die
menschen zu sehen mit denen man spricht
sie im selben raum zu haben ist etwas
anderes als in eine kamera zu schauen
und dann zu versuchen auch da ein
bisschen emotionalität auch
herüberzubringen das ist sehr viel
schwieriger
wie geht es deswegen gar nicht um die
frage wo bin ich besser wo habe ich die
besseren chancen sondern wir müssen und
das meine ich jetzt wirklich ganz ernst
wir müssen unsere personalentscheidungen
treffen
das geht jetzt im nächsten jahr so
schnell wir haben möglicherweise sechs
landtagswahl 5 in jedem fall im nächsten
jahr wir haben die bundestagswahl am 26
september aller voraussicht nach das
heißt wir sind mit dem datum unseres
parteitages noch gerade mal acht monate
vor der bundestagswahl entfernt da
liegen die osterferien die
landtagswahlen die sommerferien
dazwischen seine extrem enge zeit die
uns zur verfügung steht und deswegen wie
auch immer es geht es geht wir müssen
die entscheidung treffen wir müssen uns
aufstellen für diese bundestagswahl 2120
kommt zum schluss unseres gesprächs noch
mal zu corona zurück sie sind selber an
der korona erkrankt gewesen
wie hat sie das verändert hat dass ihre
einstellung verändert ihre einstellung
zum leben wir haben jetzt empfunden da
wissen sie vorgehen ich habe immer schon
großen respekt und große dankbarkeit
empfinden für meine gesundheit
ich habe einmal als junger
bundeswehrsoldat viele monate wegen
eines unfalls im krankenhaus gelegen und
ich weiß hat derzeit was es wert ist
gesund zu sein und das habe ich auch
immer als meinen lebens grundsatz mit
beherzigt und er hatte glück dass ich
nur leichte bis mittlere symptome hatte
ich habe außer meiner frau die gar
nichts gemerkt hat niemand angesteckt
ich habe gott sei dank meiner eltern
nicht angesteckt die beide noch leben
aber beide über 90 92 und 96 jahre als
sind ich war genau in der woche meine
information noch bei ihnen also insofern
viel glück gehabt aber auch eine menge
mehr respekt noch mal zusätzlich
gewonnen und wir alle müssen das ernst
nehmen und wir sehen ja nun auch schwere
fall
bei menschen die viel viel jünger sind
als ich wir haben eine steigende zahl
von todesfällen von minden menschen die
einfach an dieser erkrankung sterben so
und von daher bitte respekt auch wenn
man anderer meinung ist was die
massnahmen der regierungen betrifft wir
alle wissen wahrscheinlich erst in ein
bis zwei jahren aus der rückschau was
dann vielleicht besser gewesen wäre
aber jetzt muss jeder seine
verantwortung wahrnehmen auch als ganz
normaler staatsbürger in diesem lande
schmerz vielen dank für das gespräch
dagegen sehr
[Musik]